aliens fire team elite is finally out
and while the game looks like a simple
action experience on the surface it's
actually full of deep character
customization varied enemies and
impressive weapons to unlock here are
some tips and tricks to help you survive
in the war against the xenomorphs as
well as understand the game's various
systems for keeping your colonial marine
powered up and frosty if you want more
aliens fire team elite coverage then
check out our review in the description
below and don't forget to hit subscribe
for more videos if you're in the uk like
me they mostly come at night
mostly
aliens fire team elite has four classes
to choose from when you begin the game
as well as a fifth one that unlocks
after the main campaign has been
completed so which class is right for
you that all depends on how you prefer
to play team based games as you'll be
able to choose between offensive
defensive and support classes to survive
the xenomorph hordes the gunner is a
well-rounded attacker the demolisher is
great for clearing out entire swarms of
cannon fodder the technician provides
plenty of support firepower and the
medic will keep your team in the fight
against even the most overwhelming odds
having a well-balanced team is the key
to success with each class bringing
signature tricks and firepower to each
encounter nothing stopping you from
assembling a team of three demolishers
though and aliens fire team elite allows
for even that squad to still have plenty
of variety thanks to how you can level
up your classes and invest in their core
abilities
this one goes without saying but don't
forget that every xenomorph has acid
blood pumping through its veins every
dead bug leaves a temporary acidic
obstacle in its wake although if you're
in a rush you can dodge over it to avoid
losing any of your health points just be
wary of a particular glowing green breed
of xenomorph as its tougher hide allows
it to get closer and violently explode
when it dies you'll also want to be wary
when walking down supposedly safe
corridors if one of your marines says
hear that that's a sign to stop and
examine the area for a lurking prowler
these red xenomorphs hide around corners
or hang from ceilings and if you get
close enough they'll pounce and deal
significant damage avoid this trap focus
your firepower on it and bring it down
to size before it can inflict harm on
your team but it's not just the prowlers
other xenomorphs will often bounce
around walls ceilings and cover spots to
get close to you so keep an eye on your
surroundings at all times to avoid being
ambushed by the bugs yes they are indeed
coming out of the walls if you'd like to
avoid any parasites calling your chest
cavity home for a few hours make sure
that you have your eyes open for any
eggs that house the dreaded facehugger
these eggs will spawn the vile
incubators when you get too close and
should they latch onto you you'll lose
some vital health in the process alien
fire team elite's cover may seem
pointless as xenomorphs use their
agility to close the distance but the
games swerve into cover-based shooter
territory is necessary when dealing with
synthetic androids in the later missions
unlike the xenomorphs synths are well
armed and able to demolish a fire team
from a distance with their precision aim
hugging nearby walls to avoid their
attention is vital but you'll also have
to stay alert for heavy synths who can
take more damage and units armed with
flamethrowers
switch to electrified ammo to disrupt
their patterns let nearby xenomorphs
harass them and don't forget to aim for
the head
in addition to reliable lead rockets and
proximity grenades you'll be able to
load a few rounds of elemental
ammunition into your weapons when you
find or buy the right consumables
xenomorphs may be remorseless killing
machines but fire is great for burning
through their defenses and dealing
damage over time for synthetic enemies
you'll want to switch to shock rounds
that overload their circuits and leave
them open for a counter attack it's
worth noting that whenever you activate
this special ability from your inventory
wheel it will only apply to the weapon
you have in your hands so think
carefully about which firearm you want
to load the ammo into while every class
is equipped with weapons and skills that
makes them valuable the demolisher is
the go-to class for players having a
hard time landing shots on xenomorphs
demolishers can choose between the smart
gun and flamethrower as their secondary
weapon when starting out with the former
featuring an auto lock-on option that
targets the nearest enemy to you and
unleashes a barrage of rounds the smart
gun has a meaty magazine as well
allowing it to easily annihilate an
entire horde of xenomorphs when you hold
the trigger down the flamethrower barely
requires any aiming though as you merely
need to point it in the general
direction of anything dangerous and burn
it to a crisp when you pull the trigger
like the smart gun the default magazine
size is massive and you'll be able to
clear rooms with this weapon while
applying burn effects to heavier enemies
you'll be able to experiment with
different loadouts in your home base
aboard the endeavour where you can dig
into the weapons available in each
loadout and find the build that suits
you best once you've got a character
wielding weapons that works for you
stick with them as you can level your
arsenal up once you've killed a few
thousand xenomorphs a weapon at its
maximum level will deal more damage and
handle better thus also increasing your
overall combat rating spread your
selection of weapons across your various
classes to have them consistently gain
experience it may look confusing at
first but alien fireteam elite system
for growing your marine is actually
pretty easy to understand leveling up a
marine unlocks slots in their skill tree
as well as new abilities and perks some
of these skills are locked into a
specific class others benefit all five
loadouts that you can choose from the
unifying factor here is that there's
only so much space for you to slot your
skills into leaving you the option of
investing in being an all-rounder or
specializing in a certain field for
example the demolishers shoulder-mounted
micro-missiles can be upgraded into a
widespread of napalm projectiles that
leave a lingering field of fiery death
behind after they've exploded if you'd
prefer for your core skills to be
enhanced instead you can add tabs that
buff your reload speed and the maximum
amount of ammo you can carry it's worth
checking in with the officer in charge
of supplies as you can grab a few
universal perks from him provided that
you have enough currency on hand
while your regular xenomorph is no match
for a small burst of high velocity led
from a tried and trusted m41a pulse
rifle there are plenty of other enemies
that can take a significant amount of
damage before they finally fall besides
hearing your commanding officer
frantically shout about these xenomorph
variants appearing you'll spot them on
your radar as teal or orange blips these
hostiles should be a priority target
when they're in range as it takes a
barrage of firepower to destroy their
armor and knock them down keep the
battlefield clear unleash your special
abilities and aim for the weak spots to
deal enough damage to take down these
brutes before they can disrupt your
party while every ambush point in a
level has a crate or two with some
useful gear you never know what you're
going to get as the inventory is always
randomized alternatively it's always
worth spending a few credits at the
requisition store so that you have
access to combat boosts that complement
your character whether that's a turret
that shoots incendiary rounds or a drone
that makes enemies weaker a small
investment before a mission goes a long
way towards completing a run and banking
the rewards at the end of it there's a
hidden cache in each level usually
tucked away in a section of the map
that's off the beaten path and it's
worth hunting for inside each cache
you'll usually find a handy consumable
item unlock new cosmetic gear or remotes
or weapon accessories if you're playing
with friends they'll have to open the
cache individually to gain the gear
inside so make sure that you pop an
alert whenever you find one
while it's tempting to go or gung-ho as
you take on the xenomorph and synthetic
hordes that's a recipe for a quick death
you'll want to stick close to your
teammates especially those members in
your party who can provide several
beneficial buffs to the offense-heavy
members of your squad medics can lay
down a drone that provides a constant
stream of health while recon members of
the team will keep your guns loaded with
an ammo generating pod perfect for when
you want to take down a swarm while
using the best tools in your arsenal
increasing your character and weapon
levels in aliens fight team elite can be
a grind but if you're looking to
shortcut the process while adding a fun
challenge to the game then it's well
worth looking at activating a challenge
card earned through completing tactical
opportunities and finding hidden caches
and available for purchase from the
requisition store these cards can
transform how a level plays into a wild
experience tired of gunning down runners
there's a card that turns all of them
into explosive bursters if you're up to
the challenge the choice is yours and
the end result is a big increase in the
experience points and resources that you
earn at the end of an encounter if
you're lucky you might even unlock an
exotic card that offers great rewards
for merely completing a level one thing
to bear in mind though is that only one
card can be active at a time and if all
three players activate a challenge card
the game will randomly choose which one
to use cards are also consumed when you
use them so make sure you're confident
that you can handle the increased
difficulty tactical opportunities offer
you special objectives to complete in
exchange for resources experience points
and other goodies players have two daily
bounties and one weekly extra mission
objective to pursue so far these
optional missions have ranged from
playing two missions with a different
class shooting a number of facehugger
eggs or even taking down 300 enemies
with a handgun they're worth attempting
as the rewards for completing a tactical
opportunity include a substantial amount
of credits and bonus gear all handy
stuff for building your marine into a
lean and mean fighting machine there are
two constants in the universe first in
space no one can hear you scream and
second red barrels will always be the
best makeshift explosive to use when
taking on the worst the galaxy has to
offer so
you know
shoot the red barrels that just about
does it for our tips to get your marine
fighting fit to face the xenomorph horde
if you've got any more suggestions leave
them in the comments below hit like if
you've enjoyed the video and subscribe
for more videos like this this is chris
last survivor of the endeavour signing
off
[Music]
you